[Musique]
alors vacances de noël approchant oblige
d'une grosse programmation cette semaine
aussi 17 avec deux sorties nationales
le blockbuster de chez warner aquaman en
2d 3d vfb au donc sur nos écrans cette
semaine est aussi le dernier disney leur
tour de mary poppins la suite attendue
des aventures de mary poppins puis plein
d'autres films de qualité
pupilles de génériques reprenons cette
semaine dwayne rhapsodie pour les fans
de queen et aussi les autres qui
connaissent pas la vie de freddie
mercury toujours super vfv aux robins
des bois le grand bain pour ceux qui
n'ont pas vu les disney de noël tous les
ans une petite opération passe des vieux
disney nos classes et cette semaine
c'est cendrillon et monstres et
compagnie astérix toujours et secrets de
l'appelation magique pour les familles
et un log riche aussi est ainsi défini
pour les tout petits
mimi elisa les lumières de noël dimanche
matin à 10h30 et bonne fête à tout le
monde pour cette fin d'année
[Musique]